eine tosca und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja hatte ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut ich bin hier in
meinem büro
ach so der ist hochgefahren der
staubsauger wir heute wieder mal was
spannendes vor
ich habe nämlich zwei bestellungen
gemacht also die mit amazon zu tun haben
erstmal muss ich sagen es ist ultra
schwer an geile amazon retouren
restkosten ranzukommen in deutschland
ich habe das jetzt soweit wahrscheinlich
hat zum letzten mal kurz angeschnitten
amazon deutschland verkauft diese ganzen
rest waren nicht nach deutschland
sondern alles ins ausland das heißt es
ist schwer daran zu kommen
trotzdem habe ich es geschafft ich habe
einmal ein paket gekauft von ebay für
300 euro
mit amazon retouren ja ich denke das ist
weniger geil
als das paket für 1100 euro mit amazon
restposten der tipp kam von einem
kollegen von mir das auch so ein
bisschen in die wege geleitet das steht
alles gerade noch da wir starten heute
erstmal mit dem paket für 300 euro
vielleicht sei ja trotzdem gute sachen
drin berlin ist hinter der kamera meinem
bruder damit auch hin und wieder
vielleicht jetzt zu sehen sein
wir haben hier einmal ein paket du
kannst ja mal runter füllen dann haben
wir hier noch die beiden sachen die
ebenfalls dazu gehören das auch
natürlich dass hier auch ja also das
gutachten die auch alle ja ja
[Musik]
ja passieren wahrscheinlich gesehen da
kam so eine riesige palette an also das
recht schwer das alles zu kriegen aber
wir werden sie gleich hinterher gut
zusammen dabei ich würde sagen ich stehe
einfach erstmal hier mit und den rest
machen wir dann gleich irgendwie es wird
ein bisschen chaotisch heute aber wir
schauen man also das problem bekommen
ich glaube auch dass wirklich ziemlich
viel schrott dabei sein wird aber wer
weiß das hier ist das erste was oben
drüber war das in zwei krücken die eine
entstanden ist so ein bisschen kaputt
größten auktion bestimmen
das ist in zwei unterschiedlich wobei
gleich lang sind die schon ne wenn ich
jetzt mein fuß gebrochen hätte würde ich
dir benutzen
ich weiß nicht und was auch schon drüber
war ist dieses paket ich habe keinen
plan was das ist ich glaube das ist ein
zelt im garten ja fast vollständig das
ist eigentlich nicht ich weiß es nicht
genau das muss man natürlich ganz klar
sagen bei diesen amazon retouren
restposten man muss alles kontrollieren
das ist auch echten aufwand um zu
checken funktioniert das noch ist das
ist ja irgendwas beschädigt weil das
kannst du halt nie wissen und ich will
ja auch keine scheiße verkaufen ihr
könnt ihr meine kommentare schreiben was
ihr glaubt was das ist ich versuche auch
gutes gehen zwischendurch immer die
preise hier mit einzublenden sowie es
kennt dann würde ich sagen machen wir
hier mit weiter das ist ziemlich schwer
eine gute mikrowelle von severin leute
wir haben das problem bei der mikrowelle
dass immer die sicherungen raus fliegt
würde ich mal sagen kein gutes zeichen
der sache muss ich auf jeden fall noch
mal nachgehen wir machen weiter wir
können jetzt gerne die restlichen pakete
auf meinem tisch auspacken dann kann man
ihn auch mitmachen das ist aber ich doch
'ne menge oh man sollte wer mit 15
kartons die wir jetzt einmal auspacken
müssen und dann obama mir das durch weil
das video kann
hier ist einfach baby baby dinge ins
bett als er damit reich einst lebte ja
selbst bestimmt schon zehn jahre alt
aber hier haben wir wirklich einen guten
hp-drucker ich kann mir nur vorstellen
dass wir auch gegen dieses recht ist
oder ultraschall reiniger da ist dann
halt noch mal die mikrowelle bringen die
gleichen
das ist kaputt
es ist doch das gleiche was hier noch
mal ein paar mal zu weihnachten also man
kann da so was er rein kommt man kommt
damit raus habt ihr vielleicht in einem
der letzten videos machen da ich hier
auch dass wir nicht mal ein kabel dabei
danke dafür auf jeden fall
ich habe den text vor gefragt sind die
sachen alle defekt er meinte nein soweit
neues paket wir haben jetzt zweimal
marina und 310 absolutes von aquarien
und da kannst du eine pflanze darin
wachsen lassen
und das ist da ihr für die zukunft alles
kaputt sind aber das kann ich so
gebrauchen weil meine fenster hier sind
so dreckig die muss ich auf jeden fall
mehr säubern noch einmal fangen ja hier
kannst du dich wegen der berge von casa
design waren sie ganz kriegen aus
nämlich einfach mal mit pc boxen von
logitech ist nicht von mir trinken
würden dort von logitech mal klar wie
gesagt die preise sind hier manchmal
eingeblendet sonst berechtigt alles am
ende noch mal grob zusammen
und dann gucken wir macht kannst du noch
eine gute tastatur gebrauchen
gerade ist eine gaming tastatur das ist
das neueste vom neuesten noch meine
waage dann haben wir hier
guck mal schöne und halter haben wir
zweimal antwort und antragsteller chris
barth ich habe etwa einer woche habe ich
mir so etwas für meinen bart wohl
deswegen brauche ich das jetzt nicht
mehr leute hier haben wir einen fußball
von revlon acht die machen es gibt
keinen gott für alles also ich bin mir
auch sicher dass irgend jemand der
dieses video schaut sich denken fußball
und dann haben wir noch meine waage
kommt pakete unter nächste ist heute ist
schon mal vergessen inzwischen aber
irgendwie ist das nach glasers drin guck
mal das ist so ein sehr qualitative
sting wird allerdings einmal leicht
nutzt ein bisschen dreck ist ja das ist
ja auch wirklich kommt ist eine
frechheit leute kaufen sich das benutzen
das einmal schmeißt das wie scheiße da
ein solcher ist gras drin und dann kommt
das meinem jahren
das muss man ja auch amazon lassen man
kriegt schnell wenn man irgendwas zu tun
ist du kannst es da nicht nur christoph
zimmer geld wieder nachhaltig ist dann
was anderes aber davon scalextric eine
doch das ist so eine karriere machen
oder zumindest eine kleine alter wir
hatten noch höher auf einem von welchem
ich mache auf jeden fall war das ein
richtig richtig gute wahl
ska lag trick ist ja eigentlich keine
schlechte marke aber es sollte jetzt
nicht so die beste qualität oder muss
ich einmal nur anschauen scanner oder
ich würde sagen das ist vielleicht ein
laborgerät alexa alex marx mit alexis
aus dem wasserkocher kommen haben wir
gleich zweimal
ach nein das ist ein luftbefeuchter von
sabina ist kann man der kostet sogar
hier 42 euro erzeugt so kann man davon
ich habe noch keinen plan auch
funktionieren und hier haben wir noch
von samsung
das ist das prinzip ist das mindeste ist
kein mini printer ja auch ein drucker
noch ein also zwei drucker drucker
kosten auf mindestens 60 70 euro gut ich
kann dir natürlich nicht mehr so viel
geld bekommt aber ich habe ja immer noch
eindruck habt schon viermal in hardware
des checks 37 50 steckt dann mal kurz
einmal gucken doch der geht sicherung
raus leute ich muss sagen an sich bin
ich ganz positiv überrascht ich hätte
gedacht da ist wirklich nur scheiße drin
da kommen wir jetzt auch schon zum
letzten paket und man sagt er so schön
das beste kommt zum schluss soll das
haben wir jemals ein richtig geiles mit
8 11 uhr also können wir das
bewerbungsgespräch ball anstellen wenn
ich einen bei mir einstellt will er
weiter hast du so sachen die mir ist das
sehr positiv aufgefallen
was ist das mal kurz so wird bei ihr
nicht so viel einfacher
also hier haben wir jetzt wenig
elektronik damit ist das was machst du
so recht ob sie ja ich konnte hier nur
ich muss hier nur an einem tag statt
irgendwas mit ein kleiner wuchs in der
deckung
dann haben wir noch büro er hatte also
das paket was ist das peanut butter
lecker also das geld abgenommen
dann würde ich auf jeden fall noch essen
gehört was ist das so ein heizlüfter
daher sind hier noch drei werte sind die
teuer kosten müssen ja leute man sonst
ist hier nur an stellen also
irgendwelche ist gut das ist der
kameratasche glaube ich nicht und ich
habe noch eine frau unterschied von
gucci nähe von musik so es gibt ja
wirklich auch zig amazon marken die
machen einfach stimmt irgendwelche
taschen ball an da ihr logo drauf und
dann werden über amazon taschen
rucksäcke was weiß ich vertrieben
portemonnaie ist das hier ist baby a
trip to remember auch schön ich habe
auch viele mutti zuschauern das wäre
doch was für eure kinder oder leute
keine ahnung das war die 300 euro
palette wir hoffen natürlich es hat euch
halbwegs unterhalten
ich bin jetzt mal gespannt ich schau mal
wie viel das zusammen kostet was ich so
was wir zu schätzen der gesamtwert von 1
sachen wenn man das zum normalpreis
verkauft liegt auf jeden fall würde ich
schätzen bei an die tausend euro so
viele sachen gehört
oder leute was geht wir haben schon den
nächsten tagen ich habe am anfang mal
eingeblendet ich werde euch jetzt den
preis nennt für alle sachen zusammen und
so ungefähr schätzen was sich daran noch
verdienen kann also ich muss sagen das
paket war alles andere als schlecht ich
weiß noch nicht genau welche sachen
defekt sind ich denke das ein oder
andere wird auf defekt sein ich werde
das alles abdecken ich habe das mal
alles hochgerechnet nur die großen
sachen 1220 euro kosten wenn man die
neue kauf weil wir sind das alles
retouren oder restposten
deswegen würde ich hier fairerweise
einfach mal ja 40 prozent abziehen dann
laden wir aber trotzdem bei 732 euro vor
allem die ganzen kleinen sachen oder
dieses paket habe ich zum beispiel gar
nicht mit einberechnet ich meine es gar
nicht fassen hier so was zum beispiel
deswegen werde ich auch noch das ein
oder andere restposten paket schnüren
und müller war zufrieden mit dem video
ansonsten könnt ihr schauen ich stelle
es alles in meinem lucky dog ii.de shop
da lohnt es sich auf jeden fall
jederzeit reinzuschauen und falls ihr
irgendwas da kaufen sollte und dass dann
defekt ist dann meldet euch eine lösung
ich hab ja auch ein gutes team bei lucky
dog ii.de
ansonsten ich freue mich sehr auf das
1100 euro paket weil ich glaube dass ist
das wird wirklich next level also dass
so viele sachen drittens auch coole
sachen dann hast du dabei war es und wir
sehen uns wahrscheinlich in drei tagen
wieder dann kommt das video dann bist du
schon heute aber den kanal hotline ciao
ciao weil wir ganz kurz noch zu diesem
peanut butter ding das ding ist schon
abgelaufen
vor drei monaten und hier hat sich so
eine ganz komische klebrige schicht
gebildet das schmeiße ich mal besser weg
so kann man das sehen
oha kommen das muss ich sein dass man
manchmal dazu